[Music]
former president Donald Trump has been
in court a lot lately hush money
payments illegally possess classified
government materials his attempt to
overturn the results of an election we
have seen nothing approaching this
before with respect to these indictments
of Donald Trump trump now faces four
trials from two federal indictments and
two State indictments
here's how Trump's legal team could
Mount their defense and how these
charges could influence his 2024 bid and
those of his rivals
a Fulton County grand jury returned a
true bill of indictment
the Georgia indictment charges the
former president with 13 felonies for
trying to undo his 2020 election defeat
in the state the probe hinges on a key
piece of evidence a recorded phone call
then president Trump made to George's
top elections official Brad
raffensberger I just want to find
uh uh 11 780
votes which is one more that we have
Trump has said that he did nothing wrong
and the call was quote absolutely
perfect I think that the strategy here
sort of the umbrella strategy that it's
a quote unquote Witch Hunt
on multiple fronts
to stop him from regaining the
presidency that's not really a legal
defense that's more of a public
relations defense but you know he
obviously has people who are buying into
that theory one reason the Georgia
indictment is different from the federal
cases is that even if Trump were
re-elected as president let's presume
he's convicted in Georgia federal
government president has no pardon power
over those State convictions in Georgia
the State Board of Pardons and paroles
doesn't consider pardon applications
until five years after an individual has
completed their sentence so he could be
conceivably under the most outlandish
scenario sitting in prison and still
being the president of the United States
Trump's alleged conduct in Georgia also
plays a role in a federal case accusing
him of trying to subvert the will of
American voters
on August 1st Trump was indicted by a
Federal grand jury in Washington the
indictment brought by special counsel
Jack Smith charges the former president
with four criminal counts for his
actions that culminated in the January 6
Capital riot
we watch the January 6 case is clearly
the most significant case it's the most
comprehensive the attack on our nation's
capital on January 6 2021
was an unprecedented assault on the seat
of American democracy Trump has a right
to challenge the election results Trump
has a right to speak out even lie about
the election results Trump took his
right and went to court and lost every
single significant case that should have
been the end of it we fight like hell
and if you don't fight like hell you're
not going to have a country anymore for
the defense they've already laid some
seeds for their their approach one is to
delay the case as long as possible the
second thing is to allege that he was
merely exercising his first amendment
rights and I think you know as in most
criminal defense cases and I've been a
criminal defense lawyer for a number of
years myself you try to distract the
jury from the evidence by raising things
like the first amendment and other
issues which I think they'll do in a
social media post Trump said the case
was a pathetic attempt by the justice
department to interfere with the 2024
presidential election when you look at
what's happening this is a persecution
of a full political opponent this was
never supposed to happen in America
in June Trump was indicted for his
handling of classified documents marking
the first time in history that the
federal government has brought charges
against a former president the case also
led by Jack Smith alleges that Trump
deliberately withheld sensitive
documents at his Mar-A-Lago Resort in
Florida even after prosecutors requested
their return last year this is really an
obstruction of justice case this is not
a possession of classified documents
case yes you could have left office and
accidentally or on purpose taken some
documents that you shouldn't have but
once you know you're supposed to give
them back you can't then lie about it
and hide them and engage in various
schemes enlisting other people to help
you do that Trump has complained that he
is being treated unfairly since
classified documents have been found in
the possession of other high-ranking
politicians they've tried to create a
false equivalency between Trump's
handling of documents and the handling
of documents by others okay well Mike
Pence and Joe Biden had classified
documents which they immediately
returned
as soon as they were alerted Smith added
new charges on July 27 alleging that
Trump and a maintenance worker sought to
delete surveillance footage from
Mar-A-Lago so it couldn't be turned over
to a grand jury
Trump has said he's an innocent man
the April indictment of Donald Trump for
allegedly falsifying business records
marked the first time in U.S history
that a former president has faced
criminal charges the Manhattan DA's case
is a case that doesn't necessarily have
anything to do with the fact that Trump
was President of the United States it
has to do with the fact that he
apparently paid hush money to a
pornography actress and tried to conceal
it which you know at the end of the day
he's not the first person nor will he be
the last who does something like that
Trump has pleaded not guilty in the New
York Florida and Washington DC cases it
remains to be seen how each trial will
play out in court Trump's team I think
that their strategy has got to be to
delay as long as possible the other
strategy that they have is to try to try
this case in the court of public opinion
as opposed to in the courtroom where
they can make these arguments that
aren't really legal defenses like
Trump believes that he actually won and
I think that's going to be hard for them
to
convince a jury unanimously that that
was the case here even if the defense
doesn't convince the entire jury a hung
jury could still be considered a win for
Trump all that Trump has to achieve in
any of these cases is one juror who's
voting against the other jurors so 11 to
1 for him would be a victory and then
the prosecutor would have to decide do I
want to retry this case
while recent polls show Trump has a
commanding lead over the rest of the
Republican field his legal troubles have
taken a chunk out of his campaign
finances recent data show that his main
political committee save America shelled
out more than 20 million dollars on
legal related expenses so far this year
but the indictments have also helped
Trump fundraise in the days following
the indictments his campaign
contributions increased by millions the
critical thing will be the trials and
whether he is convicted and the
conventional wisdom is you know this may
help him his base will unite behind him
they've softened a bit yes we still love
Trump but we really want to go through
all of this again or do we want to look
forward Trump may also have to navigate
attending various court dates while he's
campaigning it's possible he could have
four trials before the November election
Each of which could take many weeks in
other words during the prime campaign
season he could be tied down in court
and as for his political opponents on
the 2024 campaign Trail you know if
DeSantis and Nikki Haley and Tim Scott
and others hope to bring down Trump I
have to go after him kind of what
they've done so far tiptoeing around
these incredibly serious charges against
Donald Trump is going to do absolutely
nothing for them
[Music]
[Applause]
oh